uh you find that married couple families
were much more prevalent among blacks
then than today most black kids grew up
in homes with two parents under slavery
itself and for Generations thereafter
and as late as the 1960s most black
children grew up in two parent homes
when you think about it I mean uh
centuries of slavery and generations of
Jim Crow did not destroy the black
family
but one one generation of the welfare
state it wasn't until the welfare state
so now we're talking about the early
1970s when basically the Democrats came
in and they came in with affirmative
action and they came in with all these
handouts that suddenly the black
community started to break down in the
home this is just a fact there's nothing
racist about talking racist by talking
about that right